I come to this video playing sepi one I
have played him once for add wrong let's
see the Italian game playing with Bishop
e7 year he didn't play Bishop 95 this
early attacking move this way yeah I
think he d 5 is actually good but I
don't really know that line too well I
have my own my own recipe him try to
play for f5 but ok he has not castled
yet as long
hmm this happens when you play too
quickly really you find that at least it
happens to me and find that I confuse
things and do do do little little
inaccurate moves that very often i
damaged my chance is considerably reason
why I'm often so critical about super
fast play in the opening you cannot
really repair things that you are let
you screw up there okay one Bishop g5
here increasing pressure on my center
yeah that wasn't a very successful
opening King edge aid was too early the
idea is not interesting with Nigerian
and so on but it wasn't a very good idea
and a specific position yeah but still
it looks like like relatively equal
position I can try to k it's just
trading down stuff queen is good only
six covering be three maybe I get in 97
c 5 something like that
that's not a particularly exciting
position in fact this happens quite
often in the Italian game it's one of
them less exciting openings to face
sometimes
I really don't have much else
yeah got everything cavity king coming
coming heightened King coming here and
okay he had an idea I wasn't really sure
what he what he did wants to try to get
the 90 m i have ninety-seven now
covering this the whole thing has some
decreased the pressure that white had on
my on my g5 pond okay what is this mike
and i can just take here and now
probably ninety seven yeah be 4i have 96
that's not doing much
want to use the King here right now I
can play 95 actually I have covered f6
and maybe here and f5 okay maybe a
marking let's gain space here why not
he's not very active before this I was a
for hanging ok now he's trying to
prepare it should I go knight c6 I can
do it just just prevent before for the
moment
sure that
still not a terribly exciting position
okay
wait to die play that this bit relaxed
maybe
if i take here take on before this was
my idea takes takes c6 take on c3 I'm
just promoting Noah click and go to be
three okay and that's an interesting
move that I didn't consider at all
time warning
thank you if 5mb fibers
what tech I was just and I was just
playing this far too relaxed like there
is nothing going to happen anyway and
this wasn't true I mean there wasn't
happening much but I should have
addressed this this thing of course with
da porn check
check it's always frustrating when even
even bad technical moves to do win
against you check
check black workers on time yeah I was
far too relaxed him far too relaxed I
mean here be a black is even better of
course but i didn't i didn't play this
well at all IMF for was a pretty stupid
idea I should just take you for of
course then maybe getting the night of
60 or 90 f 6 cm of course no and for
it's very stupid yeah this is this is
this is the best just by far the best
way to play intending to reroute the
night here that's quite simple and just
good for black just just a question how
good it is but it's better for lucky
yeah for worst you I thought long-term I
can just play h5 g4 and get to the
weaknesses but okay well here there's
nothing going on really but around here
so that's simply not a good idea should
probably drop back this before ideas
still still somewhat annoying but here
it gets it gets very very problematic
no wow I really played a totally bad
game here here here again I have
relatively be chance try to defend it's
not great obviously it's just born out
of necessity but still I can try to try
to hold this now this this has still
some some slight chances to hold not
much but this is this is probably losing
there's no way now the a bonus justice
too strong no mander well yet some some
quicker wins and mentor check it down it
was it was a win all along there was no
no real hope just continuing for the
sake of it yeah but this was possibly
bad move him the f4 is just just bad mmm
how much did I take on that five seconds
now that's really totally enter
positional rules also the capture is
interesting but I'm not sure about that
i mean you can do play like that but it
seems better to me to keep the pawns on
that keeps more space in a way yeah f4
is really bad the point is he could play
this later also and if i play now this
regrouping there is simply too much
pressure on White's position so that you
can never play that something like this
the [ __ ] is just getting to be very
tricky okay thanks for watching